hi there Steve here Steve Kaufman you
know we've had a lot of live streams you
know connecting with people who are
under lockdown
we've talked a bit about how people use
link I've had some conversations in some
other languages including my not very
good
Portuguese just now with in my last
video with Gabriel I don't apologize for
it it is what it is if I were in an
environment where I spoke Portuguese
more often I would improve as it is it
tends to be very much influenced by my
Spanish but today I want to talk about
the basics of language learning because
you know in many things that we learn
there's this sense that you know the
basics are very important and I think
the basics of language learning are
important I think the basics of a
particular language are not so important
and that's my first basic concept your
ability to master the basics to learn
the basic grammar to learn the basic
vocabulary sort of up front at an early
stage of engaging with the language that
ability is I wouldn't say non-existent
but extremely difficult or rare and the
reason is that with languages we are
getting used to something so some of the
most basic things we may not get used to
them until six months later and so one
shouldn't worry about making mistakes in
some of the most basic things people who
learn English make mistakes with a third
person singular of the present tense
they don't put the s in there because
they haven't gotten me used to it so
learning languages is not about nailing
down the basics learning languages is
about getting used to the language and
we do that by acquiring words and
phrases that is the fundamental task
it's not trying to nail down grammar
rules until we have enough experience
with the language those grammar rules
are not that meaningful if you are told
that German is a subject object
language whereas English is
subject-verb-object
that doesn't tell you very much because
until you're actually into the language
you really don't know what they're
talking about and you may theoretically
know it but you won't be able to
reproduce it and you won't necessarily
be able to hear that or notice that when
you're listening to the language until
you have listened enough and read enough
and once you have listened and read
enough you will probably notice that you
will already notice it and noticing is a
big part of language learning that is
another basic concept most of the things
we notice we notice them without
deliberately trying to notice them we
notice them because we come across them
so often the basic structures of the
language basic phrases basic patterns
they repeat over and over and over again
in a variety of different contexts so we
start to get used to once you are used
to some of these structures in the
language sirs you know
subject-verb-object your
subject-object-verb if you then go look
at a grammatical explanation then you
may say ah yes i know that because i
noticed that and it's also possible that
the grammar will explain some things
that you didn't notice because we don't
notice perfectly alright so words and
phrases you want to accumulate these
verses and phrases the key activity for
accumulating
words and phrases is listening you have
to understand if you want to eventually
engage with people in conversation watch
movies and so forth you have to
understand what people are saying so you
have to listen listen precedes reading
because first of all the way I listen I
listen there's a number of things I
don't understand then I read the very
same text and that's very important it's
not that useful to listen to things
where you only understand 10% and you
have no hope of understanding the rest
so I listen then I study the text on
link I look up words and phrases
so that when I listen again I understand
a little more I still don't understand
the whole thing but I'm gradually
accumulating words and phrases the
advantage of listening upfront is that
it gives you momentum for your reading
because when we read in a foreign
language we tend to sub vocalize so we
have to know how the words are
pronounced and we don't want to rely at
least I can't rely on some kind of
phonetic or you know and particularly in
a language where the writing system is
not terribly phonetic
I need the assist of the listening and
in fact we know that good reading skills
come from good listening skills people
who have trouble reading even in their
own language are people who didn't hear
a lot of the language when they were
young or who have trouble hearing
hearing good hearing good listening
leads to good reading good reading is
where you pick up Andrew lots of reading
is where you pick up the all important
words and phrases and you start to
notice them more and more you noticed it
once here and once you've noticed it
once in some listening or in some
reading you tend to notice it somewhere
else and then you load it notice it
again while listening and so there's a
sort of a virtuous circle of exposing
yourself to so much content that you
start to notice things of course a
teacher may point certain things out to
you or you may notice by listening to if
I listen to myself speak Portuguese I
noticed the mistakes that I make and
that helps me to notice again and all of
this is giving the brain a chance to get
used to the language because the brain
is not very good at absorbing
theoretical explanations the brain is
much better at creating linkages
recognizing patterns as it gradually
gets used to a new language for the
brain to do that because the brain is
good at doing it but it does it slowly
you have to feed the brain a lot of
input listening and reading now in that
listening and reading it's important to
have a strategy this is another basic
concept that I think is very important
you want to vary the repetition with the
novelty you
cannot just push at the brain deliberate
study you know a list of words grammar
rules conjugation tables the brain
starts to push back is bored the brain
needs new things so when I start into a
new language I start with our mini
stories that link I listen to them many
many times the many stories have a lot
of repetition in them a lot of high
frequency verbs but after a while I'm
bored and that's where you have to push
yourself into more interesting new
challenging content and as the brain
gets better at dealing with this content
and it helps if you have online
dictionaries it helps if you're in a
system like link you gradually are able
to consume more and more interesting
stuff from Netflix from YouTube from
ebooks audiobooks wherever it may be so
you want to have a strategy that starts
out with a lot of repetition and then
moves into more and more interesting
challenging new things to keep the brain
happy and when the brain does something
that it thought was difficult and it
exceeds its expectations the brain is
fired up gets a kick of dopamine and
that's what you want to do so basically
that's what I wanted to say I made
myself some notes here so get in the
habit of doing a lot of listening
reading and you will start to notice
things amongst other things
pronunciation so we want to get away
from expecting you know that the way the
rent language is written and we may be
used to how things are pronounced say in
English and we see it written maybe this
is a phonetic script for Japanese but
that's not how they say it you have to
hear how they say you have to get used
to the intonation if you're learning
French the intonation is a little more
monotonous if you're into Italian it's
more up and down whichever language it
is and in Chinese of course you have
tones but you have to get used to that
intonation and you achieve that again -
a lot of listening and reading so there
you have it those are my basics for
language learning know just as I said
you know there are no Basics in the
language you have to go out and discuss
for them gradually yourself the same
holds true for language learning I have
my basics of what I have discovered
through my experience in language
learning you have to go out there and
find your own path the language learning
see what you discover see what you
notice see what are your basics and once
you have the language you don't need the
basics and once you're experienced at
learning languages you don't need the
basics so that's what I wanted to say
about the basics of language learning
bye for now